[Music]
[Applause]
ross tucker former nfl offensive lineman
host of ross tucker football podcast he
hosts the eagles preseason as their
color analyst he is a very busy man
he'll be on the call the chiefs and the
ravens sunday night football in westwood
one and he joins us now
was that uh one of those that the
raiders won or the ravens lost as we
like to ask that question ross
oh man dan uh i'm gonna i'll give the
raiders credit uh because it felt like
they won it a couple times so i'll say
the raiders won it
but there's no question that
lamar jackson's fumbles were the
difference in the game and it felt like
the ravens were really in pretty darn
good shape
other than those fumbles but that's a
big part of it yeah that's a big part of
lamar jackson as a player it's a big
part of
the football game and the way the
raiders played i was just so impressed
because i thought there were a bunch of
times when the raiders could have laid
down were gonna lay down and the ravens
would take it away i don't know i've
seen the stat it was like 80 times in a
row the ravens had won
or something like that when they had a
14 point lead so give the raiders a lot
of credit to come back against a very
good defense down two scores like that
are you sold on derek carr you a derek
car guy
i am sold that derek carr is a franchise
quarterback i am sold that derek carr is
a starting quarterback and i think
most people probably realize now dan you
can get into this debate but
if you have a top 20 quarterback and i
believe derek carr is that right some
are probably between 12 and 20 depending
on how he's playing
i think you hold on to those guys for
dear life
because if you have one of the worst
five to ten you really don't have a shot
if you have derek carr
you have a chance to go to the playoffs
do you ever get a chance go to the
playoffs and win multiple playoff games
do i think he's a super bowl
championship quarterback well i mean if
nick foles won one yes if jimmy
garoppolo should have won one a couple
years ago then yes but you have to have
a really good team around him
are you
you're acting like a lawyer here you're
making a case for your client
that's what it sounded like yeah but
like i mean i guess i don't know
are you passionate about derek carr as
your quarterback
no i don't think i am although you know
what i really liked
i really liked what he said
last night after the game
about his offensive line about the
defense he kind of he kind of got me
passionate about him as a guy maybe more
than him as a quarterback with that post
game interview what he said about zay
jones 6 am derek carr kind of got me
fired up
after the game you know what derek carr
you know what category he goes into dan
derek carr and kirk cousins a lot of
these guys
they go into the category of
man you'd rather have him than a bunch
of other guys
but you'd always rather have somebody
better you know i don't know what i
think i started like 25 games dan in my
career over five whatever how many years
it was
i got the distinct impression every time
i was playing
that the team i was on would really
rather have somebody better out there
you know like i didn't lose the game for
him
i didn't lose the game for him but they
really would rather if there was
somebody it's hard to watch
derek carr monday night after you watch
the ridiculous throw
that mahomes made the tyree kill
to give the chiefs that win against the
brown it's hard to watch some of these
guys and the plays they make
and not as a fan be like oh i want that
i want that guy cousins is fine cars
fine but i want that guy for my team
we're talking to ross tucker former nfl
offensive lineman we believe he started
25 games in his uh nfl career lamar
jackson
um
i can give you a highlight of
unbelievable stuff and then i can give
you another
highlight tape that is bad stuff there
and having those two in the same game
you're just you know you help your team
win but you help your team lose as well
what do you think the ravens will try to
get lamar jackson to do differently
against the chiefs on sunday night
yeah well first of all i can't wait for
the game sunday night it's going to be
awesome it's a huge game
obviously there's two things number one
he just can't fumble like that
you know you cannot fumble but what's
that mean of course he can't fumble he
doesn't he's not trying to
uh what it means is take care of the
ball better you know when you're in that
situation
you're not always going to be able to
escape this is not high school anymore
it's not louisville you're not always
going to be able to make a play
you can't fumble and he still misses a
few layups and he makes some great
throws i mean the touchdown andrews back
of the end zone he makes some awesome
throws dan
but he still misses some layups
and i've said the same thing about the
ravens for years now
i think that the ravens are good enough
to win double-digit games win a playoff
game maybe two
but i don't see him going to the super
bowl you gotta win three games to go to
the super bowl against good teams the
chiefs the bills the browns whatever he
just doesn't and maybe not just lamar
but the passing game it's just not good
enough
converting the layups to win three
playoff games i feel like the ravens are
in football purgatory and i'll give you
another theme the seahawks seahawks look
great on sunday but i don't think
they're really
good enough to beat tampa or to go to
the super bowl i feel like there's some
teams that are in no man's land where
they're just gonna go to the playoffs
and maybe win a game every year and then
that's it seattle in the nfc baltimore
and the afc
okay but lamar jackson's 24
how much more can he improve with his
passing
um
because it felt like he was really
reliant on running because they don't
have a running game and maybe that led
to some of these fumbles but as far as
being a pocket passer because he's going
to eventually slow down
and he's going to have to beat you from
the pocket a couple of times here
well it's interesting because it felt
like they had him do more of that last
night than we had seen the last two
years even when he was mvp it felt like
it was more drop back passing
from lamar honestly dan i think he
probably has a similar career path to
cam newton now i don't think lamar
takes as much physical punishment as cam
did because lamar is more of a speed
runner than a power runner but i
wouldn't i would not be surprised if
they had similar career paths in which
lamar has several more good seasons
and the ravens are in the mix like the
panthers were for a while there and then
eventually
you know the physical gifts are not
enough
for him to be able to have sustained
play like that in his 30s you think this
is a 10-year window
yeah and what's wrong with that by the
way no not everybody
everybody's breeze 10 years i mean you
have you have you have a mvp caliber
quarterback for 10 years that's awesome
uh the biggest surprise of week one was
what
uh probably the packers playing that
poorly i mean i i picked the texans to
win so i can't say them i picked the
eagles to win so i can't say them
i did not think the packers would come
out there and play that poorly but i'll
say this dan that i have no idea why
they fired mike pettin
he was they were a top 10 defense the
second half last year they bring in joe
berry who's never
coordinated better than like the 28th
ranked defense in four or five years i
mean you know how much variance there is
on defense four or five years never
better than like 28th and they looked
like they gave up 38 points to jameis
winston could have been more and then
offensively
boy i know they got some o-line issues
with bakhtiari out but they did not look
very good and i'm sorry but rogers did
not look to me like he had the same edge
he had last year i mean last year
rogers you could almost sense he was out
to prove something to the world he was
mad about the jordan love pick
now he just looks to me like
he looks like a yoga instructor like at
the beach he doesn't look like he's mad
and trying to prove something wrong
anymore
uh he looks like he could be my sensei
you know like yeah he looks very zen i
don't know if zen is good
great to talk to you as always bud uh
safe travels and we'll talk to you soon
sounds great that's ross tucker ross
tucker the former nfl offensive lineman
host of the ross tucker football podcast
and uh he's going to be doing westwood
one the chiefs and the ravens on sunday
night